[Music]
pewdiepie
what's up guys master speaker of
imaginary props here
what am i doing welcome back to my
favorite
tlc paul and karine
we i did a terrible job last time to
summarize
what's going on with this couple if you
don't know what's going on with this
couple
then boy oh boy do i got a story for you
take a seat take a seat sit down i need
to tell you
this is some of the weirdest thing i've
ever seen
and i've seen some weird [ __ ] [ __ ]
am i is it a pipe or a cigar
quick quick summary this is paul he went
to meet
the love of his life who lives in the
amazon rainforest
in brazil men packed five military
grade boxes to go there and his mom
i don't know where gave him her hair
very normal
she actually just uh snuck out and gave
me a little bit of her hair from her
comb
to take with her why it means a lot
they can't communicate properly with
each other so they use this app
go on my father said
hotel paul was so scared of
swimming up his urethra that he did not
just wear two layers on his pee pee
he also wear this pair of pants all
right
he's wearing pants that outfit what else
happened oh yeah
paul admitted that he was uh he had a
criminal record and before uh
letting her react to it he runs off in
the jungle what is happening
it's just very confusing and i wanted to
follow up on some of these clips that's
why i summarized it
the first thing i want to follow up on
is the
before the flight the whole military bag
thing
so apparently he he changed his flight
because uh
they wouldn't let him grab his five bags
brazil
all right uh it's five for uh brazil two
bags older
huh that's two that pay for three more
two bags only
paul actually just need two bags the
other three is his mom's
hair they're packed with it brazil yeah
i've always checked five
that's it i always check five i always
have to check two
had a set list of things she wanted for
the baby and that was my responsibility
to bring back
i need to make oh my god so this is him
coming back the second time
and he still brought five bags what the
[ __ ]
so this is not the first time he goes oh
my god i got it all confused
he has a baby now oh god i keep missing
everything
it's all airlines no airlines can cut
your nails my dude
carry more than two bags is that correct
oh god he's married now
argo doesn't allow me to go with on any
flight
with more than two backs for 30 days can
you pick two and go
mom mom please please mom how do i pick
between your
between your hair and my pee pee
protection
suit i you know i can't make that
decision mom please please this is not
going to end well
this is very very bad what's the best
i'll have to change the flight is there
any way you can do anything with the
change fee because i cannot afford
that at all just just
okay just cancel it
not going ever i don't know ever this is
bad
you can take two mom just take two
oh my god it's 30 days i take everything
i'm not coming back
she's going to be more heartbroken not
to see you in 30 days mom
and she'll understand she was probably
i'm telling you all right i don't know
we need stuff for the baby
okay we need stuff for the baby if i get
there without them you just leave the
baby back if you were to do the baby
other stuff
leave all the baby stuff we leave all
the baby stuff here then we could be a
boy
you can ship it you can do that is born
we have nothing the baby's going to
sleep on the floor
yes whatever you want to do paul fine
pick two i'll do everything else here i
don't know
okay we have to open it and look at him
okay you want to do that no
you want to do that i'll do it right now
i'll rip everything out i don't want to
see this deal
yeah you want to do that i'll do it
right now i'll put my own bags right in
front of you mom what are you gonna do
about it mom huh you trying to help me
mom sure i'll open it right now what are
you gonna do well
i went over through my mom's hair mom
huh is that what you're gonna do okay
let's put everything out you wanna
i have never seen this charlie
i can't what's happening granny's gonna
have a couch well maybe you should call
her mom
you and we just leave stuff here you
know you know i really hate my life here
at this point
i have no family support i have no
friends what are you talking about your
mommy's helping you
okay i don't have your old support on
this because you're fine at all you
don't usually listen to the people you
should and that's why
you think yeah i shouldn't get married
don't get married oh my god you're
having a family oh my god it's always
drama
oh how is that mama putting up with that
damn how mama put up with that i'm ready
to leave my life behind forever
in the united states but the problem is
nobody can fly right now
with more than two bags i got a lot of
things
so instead of flying with two packs i
decided i don't fly at all
uh gifts uh baby clothes the baby bed
plus 35 years of my life here in the
united states into five pieces of
luggage
is that everything out of there looks
like it ah
my only option is just change the flight
just wait 30 more days
this way in 30 more days and come back
with everything it's not a terrible
option
hey sweetie how are you hi you're fine
no she speaks english now
trouble how about that all the luggage
they said i can't bring oh no they can't
i can't bring the luggage
i'm not lying i'm posting on a plane
right now why
ui because my airlines that could only
take two bags
i don't know which two bags i didn't
know which ones i have to go through and
reorganize everything everything was so
cramped packed
i know i want to come back too but i
want to make sure i have all the stuff
with us
[Music]
you know the baby needs stuff yes
i'm pregnant i understand i'm coming
back but as of right now it looks like
it's gonna be about a month
drama so
uh some i didn't believe this first
but this and a lot of people didn't
believe it but i found the footage
of after they ran into the woods they
actually got robbed
oh
that's so oh god i didn't see any of
this this is so great
where the hell did he go don't let me go
in this water don't make me go in this
water don't make me go in this water
don't let me go in the peepee water he
was ready to go in the
water what a guy
yeah definitely don't go in that
waterfall
you're pushing me oh my god
he just doesn't want to go back without
he just want to mope with over there
i don't care what if he keeps going by a
snake
if we get in a dirty water and catch god
knows what but
why why would you go there bad person
that was so weirdly insightful i'm a bad
person
i'm actually she pray i never heard
anyone from tlc be that honest
at least he has that he gets my respect
for that
okay here it is
like they're just robbing people left
and right
oh my god i can't believe that just
happened
paul knew paul no
that's why he was always ready
he's got much he's got much let's go
guys
nice nice nice
i mean if that is not a sign i don't
know what is i can't believe that
happened
that's amazing i mean that's horrible
exciting announcement
first of all i just want to say big
thanks
to everyone that checked out the
pewdiepie figurine you should have
received yours by now
and i'm really sorry really i should say
thanks for not canceling me i'm sorry it
took so long to get them
they did get delayed because of covid so
it was out of our hand but i still
really really appreciate
you guys patience throughout all of this
thank you
i finally received mine what is it
hey it's got the periods on the inside
oh gotta keep the box clean gotta keep
the box clean which number did i get
nice zero
they asked me if i wanted number one but
i'm like no i want a fan to have number
one
damn so actually i never seen this
version of it because uh
i got an early prototype version of it
so this is actually
much nicer quality especially the bottom
which number did you get
you can submit your uh photos if you go
to pewdiepie
dot store people have already submitted
what do we have number 27
number 30 000 number what is that sorry
face don't do that face
that's cool it'd be cool if everyone
submit their number
you can just scroll through i don't know
100 million
remember guys the legs come off remember
that
very cool i think he will go here now
these are obviously
the most rare and precious figurines of
all time and anyone that got him
should be got them lucky because we're
never doing the number thing
ever again however we are now doing
for those of you who didn't get a chance
the beta version
it's still respectable uh but it's not
the 100 million club edition
and uh it doesn't have any number it's
just pewdiepie on it if you guys are
interested and still want to figure in
and maybe you missed out on the
opportunity
you can still get these and now there's
no waiting time on these
so if you order it there shouldn't be a
long wait like last time
there's no pre-order basically again if
you're not convinced
wait does the legs not come off on this
version oh they do
[Music]
they're just a little stiffer on this
version
that ain't gay that's just epic
there's nothing weird about that shut up
so there you have it check it out
pewdiepie.store
see you guys next time so okay back
to the future paul is in brazil
again and he calls his mom for some
advice um
i really need to talk to her i'd feel
alone overwhelmed right now
i don't know what to do he looks a lot
better he's got a haircut
how are you i'm good i hope things are
getting better there
why is the mom so oh
i'm good i think that why why is that
funny
i don't know i don't know i can't
explain it's too complex i was really
upset the other night when you were
messaged
because you were in such distress yeah
it's been stressful had everything going
on
it was really nerve-wracking for me
because i'm we're so far away
there's nothing i can do and there was
nothing i could do to help so i didn't
call it though karine's mom's been
talking a lot about how she wants uh
i see divorce she said that basically
she feels that everything ever said was
a lie
she regrets the the marriage and she
just wants me in korea and get divorced
she wants a divorce unbelievable
when you were messaging you were upset
too yeah it's upsetting
you know everything's upsetting you know
you you know what i think i think you
and kareem need to talk yourselves
and really think about what you're doing
and then this is uh this is like
paul's default pose look in the
thumbnail
just oh god you don't understand how
tough it is to be me man
i gotta have people protection i gotta
have all kinds of
she didn't want to talk she's like
pulling teeth together to talk
i mean you've been married since what
you know you met dad when you were a
teenager and you've been married since
you were high school sweetheart so i
mean
you've been making it work for years we
had a very hard first
couple of years but we worked it out you
need to talk to each other
and if you can't work it out you need to
come home
because this can't happen again and
again and again
i don't want to tell you what to do but
i think you know that's nice
one thing that brings me difficult it's
too many differences
way too many differences so in your
honest opinion do you think me and
koreans should stay together or you
think we should get divorced
i think you should make up that decision
your own girl god damn adult what the
[ __ ]
dude and she clearly thinks you should
break up because god damn me
when we talked last time i said it's too
soon don't do it you need to learn about
you know each other and everything i
already told you that
what's without everyone getting rushed
to get married everyone
everyone i gotta get married now why
aren't you married yet
you gotta figure out if you work first
i swear she looks different every time i
see her karine wants the divorce
i'm so shocked i can't believe kareem
what's the difference
how do they get married to begin with
uh
please sit down and explain to me all
the reasons why you're upset
is it wearing a body is that a
bulletproof
bed no that can't be it i'm not even
married to paul and i want to divorce
from him why does he have a bulletproof
vest
we can't wait to see what paul has been
wearing during the pandemic
you're determined not to talk to my [ __ ]
know
you know oh oh you know
that's the one you should know you
should already
know i'm sorry if i offended your family
and your culture
i would like to really work through this
he's been willing to offer a bit of his
mom's hair in a bag
i think that's pretty generous of paul i
think karine should access
you saw that karine did not accept just
accept
paul's mom's hair and look how
devastated that was for paul
will they ever be able to recover from
this i don't know
it does not work we've talked before i
do not want to talk anymore
you want divorce yes 4k divorce
bala
oh god it gets so heavy with these
couples
just get divorced i don't care god oh
yeah so i don't know how i don't know
when but
for some reason despite all they go
through
they have a baby
can you imagine like you're so close to
a divorce
you're fighting constantly let's
have a baby okay
i still have doubts but i think it's
important that the baby have you around
and your love also
and your attention i want to keep this
together
because i love you
they've been
get ready for this emotional roller
coaster oh god what am i watching just
thinking no
i can't watch this i don't want to hear
about what happened
wrong with someone's bad bad that's too
much man i can't do it
this seems extremely private and
sensitive i don't know how
no the morals of showing this i agree i
don't i
i don't even feel comfortable looking at
it i'm like no i don't see that
all right so switch forward to today
2020 what's going on with paul and
carini
let's watch are they still together it
looks like
oh and look they had a baby that's great
how you doing oh
what do we have here a little boy yes oh
you're so pretty
thank you so are they in america or
brazil
i honestly can't tell essentially
this is one of my redos yourself nice
the uh gentleman lived here
a little bit of a fixer upper as we say
probably 20 years
until he got really ill and his sister
put him in a nursing home
be careful and watch your step okay
needs a lot of work
holy crap whoa these are sold as
is yeah i don't know anything about the
plumbing
or any of that wow we got a toilet in
here okay
got twelve but i'd want a wall when you
want a wall toilet low privacy oh
yeah is there there's no air
conditioning here is there uh i don't
think
i don't think there's air conditioning
in there paul oh my god no i'm doing the
paul
face i mean i feel for people that don't
have options but oh my god
she left the slums just to get to
another slum
there's no air conditioning there's no
walsh ball she definitely should have
stayed in brazil
oh my god this gives you some
perspective right everyone's like third
world country there's third world
country that you go to america this is
american dream right here so it's just
like comfortable for you okay
what yeah yeah how can you ask that how
would you be
yeah mama's not happy you wanna keep
walking
okay come on sweetheart you'll like this
thank you not bad
be careful
this is how they get you right they show
you an absolute dump in there
then they show you something like not
the nicest in completely
like slightly better or it looks amazing
in comparison
um this one's got all the whoa it's got
like
this place got walls oh [ __ ] yeah i mean
yeah it's just like a regular bathroom
what would this [ __ ] this
place got a bathroom off yeah i mean
smaller we had to in brazil we'd have to
keep it oh this guy's got a
window neat and tidy and everything
organized
excuse me it is
i prefer my house in brazil over this oh
so the lot ran is how much 500
okay we can't afford a whole lot with
our savings 500 bucks to rent that
where no
no dude that's this is this is doable
well think it over uh give me a call
i'll see you all later we'll definitely
be in touch
okay they need to fix rent man
are you serious rent does not make sense
to me it's like another form of tax
it's in some way or another where the
rich people who sits on property just
cash in money right that doesn't seem
right of me this isn't ideal but it's
what we can afford until i can make some
money get something better
so what do you think about it you know
good yes you're no good husband
yes you're no good husband america
see everyone has this american dream
it's so good here welcome to america i'm
sorry americans you're great obviously
but 500 for that
that's an option why shut up
bruh i mean i'd be disappointed too i
don't know if it's paul's fault
necessarily
this is the last video this is the last
follow-up of paul and karine
while i was in brazil i boarded my dogs
at a training facility
it really feels great to finally have my
dogs back did you have a big thing away
i didn't even know you had dogs
we looked a few places to live and
korean hater i didn't even know you
could leave dogs at a training facility
that'd be great edgar
uh you're going on a vacation man but
someone moved out of this old house in
the same trailer park so i decided to
get it before somebody else got it
our house that's kind of cute
this is basically a studio home
everything is just one big room
and it's really small hmm
yeah maybe if you build a loft or but i
think it's definitely the best
affordable option that greeny
will accept okay how hard can this be
my man got ac installed oh that looks
beautiful well done
oh god please oh god oh
paul that's not exactly the same thing
right you just pull the thing out and go
right in the window
oh god this gave me so much anxiety oh
god people do this
oh what if i walk underneath a building
and some idiot paul guy
installed his own ac oh god i to have
god
this should not be legal i know he's not
high up but still
oh there's a moldy stinky biscuit hey
you can
clean that out to make sure satisfy here
oh
that's nasty build a little loft
build a little maybe outside extra thing
make the bed uh go flip inside the wall
yeah it could work it could work there
you go paul and kareem
saga a lot of twists and turns man
i don't know it started so with the hair
and
uh and so much the process
uh yeah i'm glad yeah proper habitable
place
considering previous options i would say
happy ending question mark i hope so
maybe that's it maybe that's the
american way of you get married really
early
and then you just forced to go through
the hurdle
and then after that i'm sure they're
gonna make it paul and karine
i'm sure they will make a sign of
approval
that's it thank you for watching see you
guys tomorrow hey
though out pewdiepie figurine
pewdiepie.store
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fox spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big
pp pre-order promotion i mean